birria at midday she shouted Russia
without Putin and said she would
continue to promote human rights I'll do
everything for those people who want
help and support and who need to receive
it from me I'll do everything I can to
help prisoners now that I have ties to
the jail system earlier her fellow band
member Maria Alyokhina made a similar
promise after being released from a jail
near Nizhny Novgorod she said Vladimir
Putin's amnesty was a publicity stunt
and not a humanitarian act the situation
in the nation in Novgorod prison I hope
will remain under my control women who
spoke out against labor law violations
should be listened to and their rights
should not be violated any more you
provoke would she knew those in the
rashad sir Alyokhina and two fellow
[ __ ] riot band members were convicted
on charges of hooliganism motivated by
religious hatred after staging a punk
prayer in Moscow's Cathedral of Christ
the Saviour in February 2012 one was
freed on probation last year the other
two had their sentence upheld public
opinion is divided they should have been
spanked on their backside and then made
to do community service and then set
free
mr. units if they did not serve out
their sentence till the end then it's
just blasphemy I'm a proud Russian and I
think it's wrong now that they are both
free Alyokhina and Tolokonnikova have
said they will continue their human
rights work together